foreign
[Music]
good afternoon everyone and uh thank you
very much for having me I'm sorry not to
be with you in Washington DC but joining
you virtually
um and so I'll kick on talking about
scaling and automating our workflows
with kubernetes and airflow
it's a lot of my
childhood and teenage years working on
farms and
any of you who will have done the same
will recognize Baylor twine now the joke
goes that you can solve 90 of your
problems on a farm with Baler twine and
this is essentially nylon string that
your cut is an off cuts from or kind of
a byproduct of
um tying up bales of hay but it ends up
being a useful tool in tying together
say a farm gate or a trailer to a um
to an ATV or even a lead for your dog
it's something that's lying around
that's tough and sturdy and largely gets
the job done and the equivalent I guess
would be duct tape and as you can see
and as many of you will have experienced
duct tape isn't really the appropriate
tool to get the job done here or in many
cases but it sort of works and it's sort
of okay up to a certain point but then
the farm analogy really is that you can
get so far with Baler twine but at some
point you're going to need real
infrastructure you're going to need
bricks and cement and so that's what I'm
going to be talking about today
so who am I I'm an infectious disease
epidemiologist working at the UK Health
Security Agency or what used to be
called Public Health England and
um like many of you I imagine at the r
Studio conference today you'll have been
an analyst of some sort in a particular
specialist area and as you've Fallen
presumably further in love with r you've
ended up becoming more of a proper data
scientist as it would have been
um back then and then you and I think
this will be a familiar story to other
that people have gone through or the
people will hope to be going through or
will inevitably find themselves going
through is
um finding themselves not having quite
the right tools either for their
specific area or more largely stand up
becoming more of a software engineer as
they're trying to create the tools for
themselves and their colleagues to work
and then once you've got those tools and
as we heard in the last talk you often
it's not the tools so much that you're
lacking but the data and so you end up
finding yourself Health spending all
your life moving data around cleaning it
linking it preparing it and then you may
as well be a data engineer and then the
final stage of transformation as you get
further and further away from analysis
is when people start to presume you're a
member of your ICT department and you
fancily decide to refer to yourself as a
devops engineer now this all boils down
to in my case having a profound love for
both epidemiology and for code but it's
uh taken
a lot for me to find
this area where I am in now which is uh
enablement of
um my colleagues and I to
analyze epidemiology and infectious
disease data
um at scale so
what am I going to be talking about
exactly that so how we replaced our
Baylor twine like Solutions are they
sort of work but we need them to be a
bit better Solutions with true
infrastructure and
clicking on
um I'm going to be talking about those
main tools that we've ended up using so
why kubernetes and what even is
kubernetes at this point and then what
do we mean by all Automation and why is
it valuable and then airflow and why it
is actually and why it's solved so many
of our problems
so the context for all of this which I
imagine will be familiar but is
important nonetheless to buzz through is
that public health agencies have
traditionally worked with maybe
hundreds of cases of each infectious
disease they specialize in each year
these are small data sets they're easy
to manage for simple analytical tools
and those traditional ones and
um the more modern ones like R and
python so there's never been an impetus
per se to begin to think about scale
or automation is you're not working at
brake tank Pace per se
and the turning point for this in recent
years has been that the both data that
is captured and the answers that we're
required to provide decision makers and
health protection colleagues on the
ground is becoming more detailed and
more complex and in the UK thanks to our
National Health Service Health Service
where care is free and standardized
um to um to a certain extent and we have
collected fantastic volumes and quality
of data from it we're needing to
understand it in much more detail than
we've ever had before so scale has
started to creep in but of course
um
the
clicking on with my slides
um where at this point where we're
needing to do more complex analysis and
so we're using more appropriate tools so
moving away from those kind of Legacy
tools that many of us would have been
taught in our infectious disease course
as a university for those
epidemiologists in the room but R
quickly becomes the lingua Franca for
our topic area it's open source it's
accessible and it's usable to all of us
and it answers all the questions that we
need it to
now covid is where we've started to
blend both that much more complex data
requirements into needing to work at
unprecedented scale going from hundreds
of cases up to millions of recorded
cases in the UK or confirmed laboratory
confirmed cases
and so we've needed to move away from
those traditional ways of working and so
some people will say well just use SQL
and you'll be fine but as we'll all know
SQL will only take you a certain way
before you need to be able to Wrangle
your data in a much more
um flexible and accessible way and so
although odbc powered workloads kind of
creep in to increase to your scripts and
your processes really you just need to
be able to do R but bigger
and that's where we come to today now
the final context is that and all of our
colleagues who work in the public sector
will know is that you have a requirement
to work
um with a high value for money and have
it maintained by rather small small
teams
um the small But Mighty teams that exist
in many public sector organizations and
then also you're expected to perform at
at least the industry standard if not
further ahead and all of that leads to
um quite strong innovation in many cases
it's a really a sink or swim and that's
really the thing covered was the sink or
swim moment for us now in the UK we're
very lucky in that the UK government
prefers open source it's a written down
um
kind of truth that in order to be I have
achieving high value for money you need
to be using open source technology where
possible and so that was really quite a
nice Gateway into US using these
Fantastic Tools
so where have we come from
um we've come from a place of people
running an individual script kind of in
a standard operating procedure and then
maybe thinking okay I'm going to write
all of this out instead and run it on a
scheduled task on my laptop for a
Windows users or a chrome job for our
Unix users setting up the scheduled task
on the virtual machine when your laptop
started to feel a little bit unrobust
needing to have your laptop on all the
time and that's really the kind of the
beginning of where the Baylor twine
Solutions start to creep in and you're
finding yourself wrapping more and more
of your Solutions in bits of tough nylon
string trying to keep it together and
that's when you need to start pushing
into having that place of having more
robust infrastructure so you might set
up a Cron job on an older tool like
slurm or um if in more modern cases on
kubernetes and then finally getting to
that true infrastructure having both an
orchestration tool and a compute call
tool of having your dags in airflow
running on kubernetes and I'll explain
what those mean at the moment so what is
kubernetes what are we talking about so
kubernetes first is open source it's a
cloud native Computing Foundation tool
that's become pervasive in running
um typically web apps but now
increasingly data science to workloads
um across the world now
the use of container images moving away
from when it works for my machine to
therefore shipping the entire operating
system and all of your system packages
and those container images popularized
by Docker which everyone will have heard
of and they're slightly less popular but
increasingly upcoming podman tool
providing very similar functionality
and kubernetes extends that idea of
running your workloads in container
images and spec instead of having those
container images running on your laptop
they allow you to orchestrate having
those container images run anywhere so
you could have kubernetes on your laptop
you could have it anywhere and I'll come
on to that in a moment but you specify
your software your operating system in
your container image and then you apply
resources your compute your memory your
storage into
um in your pods and run those together
now pods are entirely isolated which is
either very helpful or not helpful at
all in which case you can configure them
to not be isolated from each other very
specifically but it provides that great
deal of security and reassurance that
your workloads can co-exist
um in whatever environment you have
created now the UK Health Security
Agency we prefer the red hat flavor of
kubernetes known as openshift and I'll
talk a little bit about that now because
it's easy to use cons continuous
integration and continuous delivery it
has those add-ons and I think everyone
particularly those are Studio on our
posit fans will know that using open
source tools is certainly cost effective
but there does become a time where
paying for the expertise and the tools
that are enable enable the easier use of
those open source tools is really
worthwhile and that's certainly the case
with openshift in our opinion
so that continuous integration
continuous deployment is more of a
devopsy term but to the user what's
important is that you can have your
gitlab or GitHub repository containing
your code and whenever you pushed your
master Branch say that code is
replicated
um into your container image in
kubernetes or openshift ready to go
running just as it would do on your
laptop and allowing you to push that
workload into whatever literal
environment you want now why have we
used it and that's primarily because you
want to use fewer resources because
instead of having a virtual machine per
task configure just the way you like it
you configure for each of your workloads
exactly the operating system the system
packages your code and any of your
connections all into one bundle and you
can put that onto one place and then use
fewer
um volumes of compute and storage
capacity which is going to be saving
money so increasing that value for money
as a startup
it's also easier to manage for ICT
administrators and I think all of us
will feel either hamstrung or very sorry
for our ICT colleagues particularly in
the public sector where you want to make
their life as easy as possible so you
they can make your life as easy as
possible and having all of your
workloads standardized or at least with
a standard definition
is incredibly helpful for the simplified
management of those resources
and the other great thing about
kubernetes as well as it being open
source is that it runs anywhere you can
have it available in the public cloud
like as your AWS or gcp in the hybrid
Cloud if you're from a larger
organization or on premises or even on
your own laptop when you're doing
development
and then kubernetes as I said is frankly
already the way forward or increasingly
pervasive for running containerized web
applications and microservices and
although data science is lagging behind
it's got a lot of
tools and projects that are propelling
um into being
um more and more commonplace
so then airflow the second piece of our
puzzle or the second piece of our true
infrastructure and solution and again is
open source from the Apache software
Foundation it's a workflow scheduler
which means that you it's similar to a
Cron job and one of the funniest ways of
it ever being described as always when
it was described as Apache fancy cron as
opposed to a battery airflow or maybe
cron plus plus because it gives you not
just scheduling something to say I want
to run this command at seven seven a.m
every day
um seven days a week you can say not
only that but also email me when there's
a problem or I want to see all of the
details of how which days it succeeded
which days it failed how many times it
tried to retry itself and so on and so
forth It's just got those added extras
which give you instead of having a
myriad of uh
tasks and custom scripts with their own
monitoring and logging in them airflow
offloads that so anything that you you
can offload all of that thought
um to airflow itself
now you define your workflows and
directed acyclic graphs or dags that's
more commonly referred to and now dags
is not an uncommon phrase to those in
data science if any of you any of you
use the targets r package you define
your work in a dag or so those who work
in machine learning quite often will
have this but for those who don't know a
dag is simply a set of tasks and the
relationships between tasks that show
the dependencies between one thing
having having happened and the next
thing having happened and airflow
manages all of its workloads in dags now
dags in airflow are very simple because
you have a simple code AS configuration
although it's written in Python to an R
user who hadn't written any python
before he started using airflow it's
remarkably simple so don't let that
certainly
um put you off
and then this allows you to do anything
from as simple as running an R script
just an arbitrary arbitrarily to find
our script to setting up airflow to be
linked to your Hadoop cluster or any
other large compute cluster
or other data processing tool now
airflow is incredibly flexible which is
fantastic because it fits a wide variety
of use cases but at ukhsa we've decided
to Define that into a very opinionated
setup not making use of much of that
flexibility and instead trading that for
a user-friendly simple to learn State
um which I'll go into detail more about
now so how have we use these together
have we melded these together and why is
that useful so each team has its own
kubernetes namespace so-called or a
project if you're using openshift
specific language and that allows you to
Define users resources security
and other details about all of your
workloads that mean you can have tenants
different teams within the organization
and many
um both
public sector and private sector teams
will know that not everyone in your
organization should see all of your data
you've often got to specify it down so
having those individual tenants Within
in your organization is incredibly
helpful and also just allows you to make
sure no one's getting in their own way
or getting in each other's way even and
then in when you integrate that with
airflow you have all of your container
images all of your code all of your
credentials all set up in um in airflow
in uh openshift or kubernetes and then
you assign each dag to
um a project so a team or a a team in
their own project or namespace can have
multiple dags but each dag only looks at
it only belongs to a certain team and
that's been remarkably helpful as well
for making sure people aren't
um confused by which workload is failing
which one isn't if it's theirs or not
and then teams therefore can only see
their own project and their own dags or
their own projects in openshift and
their own dags in airflow
um which again helps keep things simple
and secure
PowerPoint letting me down
um and then within that we say every
airflow task rather than each different
task being a different operator as
they're known in airflow each task
simply creates a new pod in kubernetes
and openshift with your container image
with all of your code and then you give
it a specific command and most often in
my workloads that command is simply to
run an R script because we offload all
of the connections to our other
resources or Secrets credentials to
kubernetes where that Enterprise level
security and
um
uh Resource Management happens and then
airflow is simply telling kubernetes how
to run a pod and with what resources
and this is what we found to be after a
lot of battle testing and the user
acceptance to be the most simple secure
and easy to manage way to move workloads
from people running individual scripts
on their laptops into kubernetes and
airflow which saves as you can already
imagine you don't need me to spell out
vast amounts of Staff time and also uh
uh observability and making sure the
entire team knows When Something's
Happened rather than needing to send
teams or slack message to ask have you
run the script for today
so the important bit then is how do you
get started
well if you haven't already got started
um you can use the popular and although
not open source kind of um in the case
of Docker but tools like Docker and
podman to write and build your container
images
and then you're you're working
containers to start with at all Now red
hat with its commitment to open source
allow provides these free developer
licenses which means that you can have
your own openshift cluster on your
laptop which is the perfect way to get
started with learning how the system how
kubernetes Works itself with these
user-friendly easy to get started
add-ons that the openshift flavor of
kubernetes provides
airflow as we said was open source it's
simply a python package you can pip
install it very happily and then begin
playing with your sim with simple dags
in half an hour
and then when you want to go to the next
step how to use you're using openshift
kubernetes yourself you're using airflow
yourself it's then time to instead of
having airflow on your own computer put
it onto kubernetes you have the official
pre-built container images to run
airflow on kubernetes or on your own
computer and then after that when you've
got your workloads with small amounts of
resources on your own laptop you can say
okay I'm ready now to move on to the
main kubernetes cluster and that takes
you from the 8 16 gigabytes of memory
and eight CPU that having on a laptop up
to as large as you can possibly achieve
with the hardware that we currently have
in terms of your compute
now extra tools that you might want to
know about there are a couple that will
really help you in this kind of very
high level summary of this massively
um complicated topic both The Rocker
project providing container images with
r installed and ready to use also and
I'm not just saying this because we're
speaking at the r Studio conference our
Studios public version of the packet of
its package manager has been enormously
both time saving and helpful for having
our package binaries for Linux available
to the public it's a truly wonderful
resource which I couldn't recommend
highly enough but then actually if
you're just wanting to get started with
kubernetes not in a production sense but
in terms of doing your own development
the absolute best way to be learning and
to moving your development workloads
um into kubernetes into the cloud is
using our studio workbench which I
couldn't conduct more thoroughly and I
know that I've come up to time now so
I'm going to hold there and thank you
very much for listening
foreign
[Music]